they are the entire representation
of this era of movies right now right
and there's not really much room for for
anything else that's my problem so not
all heroes wear caves but in this case
they do simu Leo is standing up for
Marvel actors and clapping back at
recent remarks made by iconic film
director Quentin Tarantino well speaking
on the two bears one cave podcast
earlier this week Tarantino shared his
take on movie stars turning into
Superheroes part of the marvelization of
Hollywood is yeah no it's the um
you have all these actors who have
become famous
playing these characters but they're not
movie stars right Captain America is the
star right Thor
is the star uh uh I mean I'm not the
first person to say that I think that's
been said a zillion times you know but
you know but it's like you know it's
these these franchise characters that
become come a star now Tarantino isn't
the first director to criticize Marvel
movies yeah back in 2019 Martin Scorsese
chatted with the New York Times and
spoke out about his dislike for
superhero films saying this franchise
films are now your primary choice if you
want to see something on the big screen
it's a perilous time in film exhibition
and there are fewer independent theaters
than ever now these recent comments from
Clinton didn't sit well was Shang Chi
star simulio who took to Twitter to clap
back saying this quote if the only
Gatekeepers to movie stardom came from
Tarantino and Scorsese I would never
have had the opportunity to lead a 400
million plus movie I'm in awe of their
filmmaking genius they are Transcendent
oh tours but they don't get to Point
their nose at me me or anyone now simu
followed up his first tweet adding no
movie studio is or ever will be perfect
but I'm proud to work with one that has
made sustained efforts to improve
diversity on screen by creating Heroes
that Empower and inspire people of all
communities everywhere I love the Golden
Age too but it was white as hell